we're being slaughtered down here we
need love I'm coming for you
I am your death [ __ ] why have you
forsaken me poop gods when I take upon a
poop job I to it with then just getting
closer [ __ ] why does that sign say poop
on it
the turd Wizards god damn in this candy
it's for 100
I scarfed down a bag of Doritos bang
you're not dead you just got shot in the
foot you'd have to pee
oh boy here baby baby here we go okay
I'm done all right I'm done this game is
not giving a good message to the youth
of society it's gonna cause degredation
and decay that was way too intense right
off the bat it went from like no music
to instantaneously
oh my god have you ever had trouble
rolled River River river where the uses
are endless for the nomina whoops that's
not what I meant to do
I bet why is that thing doing no no no
I'll get you
I see you still have the same hat you
had before no slightly different just a
little
I can't wait for more extreme pustules
need relieving really looks like the
surface of Mars on his [ __ ] then not
urbanize has two convenient ball holders
in the front oh god damn it
I can still maneuver you ding-dong
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye